en 1950 on rencontrait son amoureux via
les amis la famille ou pendant ses
études dans les années 90 arrive les
bars et le travail mais les amis restent
indétrônables 35% des couples sauf que
depuis les années 2010 tout a changé
suivant les pays c'est jusqu'à 40 % des
couples qui se rencontrent sur internet
les sites et appli de rencontre ils sont
pour beaucoup si vous avez moins de 30
ans il y a une chance sur deux que vous
les ayez utilisés mais pourquoi est-ce
que ça marche si bien comment fonctionne
l'algorithme quels sont les profils qui
plaisent le plus et surtout pourquoi
autant de gens semblent les détester
mais continue les utiliser quand même
aujourd'hui on vous amène découvrir la
science derrière les sites de rencontres
l'amour sur internet marche-t-il aussi
bien que dans la vraie vie en 2013 une
étude prouve que les couples Internet se
marient plus vite divorce moins et sont
plus satisfaits vraiment contrairement à
ce qu'on pense trouver l'amour
informatiquement ça ne date pas d'hier
la première à avoir essayé c'était Johan
balle en 1964 à l'époque quasiment
personne n'avait d'ordinateur chez lui
les gens remplissaient des
questionnaires papier puis un algorithme
les analyser ensuite on envoyait les
résultats par la poste et les gens se
débrouillaient et ça marche les premiers
couples formés grâce à un algorithme ont
60 ans rien d'étonnant si ça fonctionne
aussi bien mais pas pour les raisons que
vous pensez est-ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé que quelqu'un vous raconte des
trucs super personnels alors que vous
vous connaissez pas tant que ça ou même
de vous dire mais pourquoi je lui dis ça
c'est normal se confier à des inconnus
c'est facile ils ne sont pas concernés
directement par vos problèmes et vous
avez pas besoin de vous inquiéter des
conséquences de vos confidences c'est
pour ça par exemple que les gens qui ont
peur du rejet ont plus de facilité à se
livrer et être honnête en ligne
l'anonymat le temps de préparer ses
réponses mais aussi l'absence de signaux
comme l'expression du visage ou
l'intonation de la voix tout ça
participe à faire tomber des barrières
sociales et vous encourage à vous ouvrir
plus facilement pourquoi c'est important
parce que révéler des informations
personnelles c'est un des premiers
moyens de créer des liens si quelqu'un
s'ouvre à vous naturellement vous avez
envie de lui faire confiance et de
révéler des choses à votre tour plus
vous partagez des choses intimes avec
quelqu'un plus vous renforcez le lien
qui vous unit ce livret aux autres à de
vrais effets bénéfiques que la science
prouver combattre le stress les émotions
négatives mieux contrôler vos muscles
cardiaques et même renforcer votre
système immunitaire il y a aussi des
avantages purement pratiques dans la
directive c'est compliqué de rencontrer
de nouvelles personnes encore plus si
vous êtes une minorité l'appli qui a
propulsé le système de géolocalisation
c'est grinder en 2009 aux USA c'est un
quart des couples LGBT qui se
rencontrent en ligne on est
naturellement attiré par des gens qui
nous ressemblent si vous avez fait les
mêmes études supérieures vos chances de
matcher augmentent de 38%, 64% si vous
avez tous les deux fréquenté une
université renommée jusqu'à 97% si vous
avez la même religion ou encore 9% si
vous avez le même type de téléphone ou
les mêmes initiales vu qu'il y a même
des sites de rencontres pour
propriétaire de Tesla Tesla dating la
seule exception c'est les introvertis
qui matchent pas très bien entre eux ça
va encore plus loin une autre étude a
présenté à des personnes des photos de
leur conjoint ou une certaine partie de
leur visage ont été remplacés par
d'autres résultats les visages jugés les
plus attirants sont toujours se mixer
avec des parties de la des personnes qui
jugent et ça marche aussi avec des
caractéristiques physiques des parents
et ça jusqu'à un quart du visage
remplacé évidemment il y a une limite on
cherche pas des copies de nous-mêmes
d'ailleurs on pourrait penser qu'à cause
de ça les sites de rencontres empêchent
la mixité sociale mais pas du tout en
France on est autour de 15 % de couple
mixte plus 3% depuis 10 ans aux USA il
frôle les 20%. et ce ratio est
généralement plus élevé chez les couples
qui se rencontrent en ligne car l'autre
avantage décide de rencontre c'est la
qualité de profil que vous croisez
rencontrer plus de gens c'est augmenter
les chances de trouver quelqu'un qui
vous correspond dans ce domaine
difficile de les battre mais pour ça il
faut que les autres s'intéressent à vous
comment avoir le meilleur profil sur les
applis on est tous égaux l'attractivité
de votre profil n'a rien d'aléatoire on
peut même noter votre désirabilité en
regardant par exemple combien de
personnes choisissent votre profil
disons que si 30 personnes sur 100
matchs avec vous vous avez un niveau de
désherbilité de 3 une fois qu'on a ça on
est capable de prédire les réactions des
gens par exemple ceux avec une note
élevée son non seulement choisi plus
souvent mais aussi plus rapidement que
les autres au contraire les notes basses
se sont souvent rejetées rapidement et
ceux qui les sélectionne hésitent
jusqu'à 5 fois plus longtemps en plus
les hommes et les femmes ne se
comportent pas de la même façon par
exemple les femmes acceptent plus
rapidement les profils avec une note
élevée mais pas plus longtemps avant de
rejeter quelqu'un qui a une mauvaise
note en moyenne les gens ont déjà pris
leur décision au bout de 11 secondes ça
signifie qu'on se base sur peu de
critères pour faire son choix et il y en
a un qui est plus important que tous les
autres c'est le physique c'est pas très
autonome même si on connaît tous le coût
de la fausse photo de profil dans
l'esprit des gens c'est plus difficile
de mentir sur une photo que dans une
description impossible de vérifier si
vous êtes vraiment milliardaire par
contre votre visage le deuxième critère
c'est le niveau d'études surtout
important pour ceux qui ont des diplômes
puis derrière tout le reste par exemple
le contenu de votre description alors là
vous vous demandez du coup si je suis
moche j'ai aucune chance bah du tout une
photo attirante c'est pas le petit chien
que vous vous en faites genre une
mâchoire qui arrive chez les mecs ou des
jambes Fides chez les filles ce qui
compte le plus dans une photo c'est
l'image que vous renvoyez par exemple
les hommes sont jugés plus attirants
quand ils ont l'air d'avoir de
l'assurance d'être authentique et
extravertie les femmes quant à elle on
l'air d'être sur d'elle tournée vers les
autres et montrer un côté féminin rend
tout le monde plus attirant
indépendamment du genre regardez ces
deux photos de moi le vrai secret c'est
d'avoir confiance en soi et ça se
ressent partout on a demandé à des
femmes de juger l'attractivité de texte
de présentation et de photos
indépendamment l'un de l'autre et ben
les gens attirés en photo le sont aussi
par écrit le pire ce que les gens n'ont
conscience se juger pas attirant ont
plus tendance à mentir sur leur
description ou retoucher les photos pour
compenser et les subsons ont pu souvent
envie de tromper leur partenaire mais
attention tous se résume pas la photo et
à la description le premier choix sert
juste à faire le tri c'est un message
privé que vous cherchez inconsciemment
des points communs avec l'autre que vous
échangez sur votre vie privée ou que
vous le bloquez parce qu'il dit des
trucs bizarres alors comment faire pour
optimiser vos chances de passer la
première phase de sélection d'abord
identifier vos qualités lister les que
vous aimez demandez-vous ce que les
autres appréciez chez vous ensuite
choisissez des photos que vous aimez
bien et qui vous représentent évitez à
tout prix de tomber dans la photo
clichée si vous vous mettez en scène ça
va se voir et vous faites sûrement une
fausse idée de ce que les gens
recherchent l'idéal c'est une photo
prise pour une autre occasion ou vous
souriez où on voit que vous êtes
sociable pour les textes libres nous
vous prenez pas trop la tête la plupart
des gens les lisent en diagonale donnez
juste des infos importantes genre le
type de relation que vous recherchez
évitez juste les fautes quand quelqu'un
les repères ça impacte très négativement
son jugement les QCM ou les cases un
foie remplir non souvent aucun impact
sur l'attirance de votre profil les gens
s'en servent juste pour vérifier qu'il
n'y a pas un truc illuminatoire chez
vous mais avant ça il y a encore un
élément à travers de votre route l'appli
elle-même la science des algorithmes
est-ce que vous savez que vous pouvez
demander l'intégralité de vos données
aussi de rencontres tout ce collecte des
millions d'informations sur vous et vous
laissent les récupérer un petit
formulaire à remplir pour retrouver des
centaines de pages de secrets comme
historique honteux de vos messages de
jeunesse ces données ils en ont besoin
pour faire tourner leur algorithme à une
époque par exemple on sait que tinder
utilisait un système d'élo oui le même
système de classement qu'aux échecs ou
dans les jeux vidéo quand vous aviez des
matchs vous grimpiez dans le classement
des gens séduisant à la verse si tout le
monde vous envoyez balader et vous
finissez en bas mais aujourd'hui le
système a évolué il utilise un système
de compatibilité l'algorithme quel
profil vous avez aimé quel type de
personne ont aimé le vôtre et enfin avec
qui vous avez match puis il va regarder
les autres utilisateurs qui ont des
goûts similaires au vôtre par exemple si
vous avez exactement les mêmes goûts que
Jérôme qui lui a eu un match avec
Christine il va aussi vous la présenter
plusieurs applis revendiquent carrément
l'utilisation de l'algorithme Gaëlle
chapelet récompensé d'un prix Nobel
prouve que pour un nombre donné d'hommes
et de femmes on peut toujours trouver
une manière de les mettre en couple qui
conviennent à tout le monde mais pour ça
en plus de se baser sur les préférences
on doit aussi multiplier les
propositions du coup le meilleur moyen
de tirer parti de l'algorithme c'est
d'utiliser l'application à force il va
cerner ce qui vous plaît et optimiser
vos chances de rencontrer la plupart des
applis avec un swipe utilisent un
système similaire ça marche bien mais il
y a quand même des petits problèmes si
vous ne savez pas trop ce que vous
cherchez ou si vous choisissez des
profils un peu au hasard vous pouvez
vite vous retrouver dans une boucle qui
ne vous correspond pas ensuite à force
de voir des profils qui sont censés vous
plaire vous allez peut-être passer à
côté de gens géniaux mais différent de
ce que vous rencontrez habituellement de
l'autre côté ça veut aussi dire qu'une
fois que l'algo vous a cerné il propose
en premier les profils qui ont le plus
de chances de vous plaire alors à chaque
fois qu'on vous dit non la personne
suivante est une moins bonne option que
la précédente c'est pour ça que
certaines applications utilisent des
systèmes différents grinder par exemple
présente en priorité les gens qui sont
actifs et proches de vous et mélangent
ça avec quelques profils aléatoires il y
a aussi les questionnaires on trouve ça
plutôt sur les sites web comme yharmonie
ou okCupid ça a quelques défauts comme
le fait que les gens ne savent pas
toujours ce qu'ils recherchent ou au
contraire qui sont sur deux mais se
concentre que sur des éléments qui ne
permettent pas de savoir s'ils vont
s'entendre avec l'autre comme la taille
ou les revenus mais globalement ça
marche plutôt bien bien parce qu'en fait
les algorithmes n'ont pas besoin de
fonctionner pour être utiles le simple
fait que le site ou l'appli vous propose
quelqu’un peu importe que j'ai raison ou
non ça a augmente les chances que votre
premier date se passe bien comme quand
votre famille ou vos amis vous disent
qu'ils aiment bien votre partenaire ça
booste votre confiance et votre
sentiment d'avoir fait un bon choix ça
se combine avec l'effet de Halo
naturellement présent sur ces sites le
fait que si votre première impression de
quelqu'un est positif vous allez lui
attribuer tout un tas d'autres qualités
inconsciemment tout ça ça fait que
parfois on match avec des gens pour de
mauvaises raisons pourquoi les sites de
rencontres vous font du mal les gens qui
utilisent des applis de rencontre ont
jusqu'à 16 fois plus de risques d'avoir
des troubles de l'alimentation 3,5 fois
plus de risques d'être angoissé ont une
moins bonne estime de ce comparent plus
souvent aux autres ou encore ont plus
peur de finir célibataire et il y a pas
forcément de lien avec le nombre de
matchs les études sont formelles plus
vous passez de temps à regarder les
profils plus vous êtes malheureux et
plus vous rejetez les gens sur certains
sites c'est jusqu'à 75% des utilisateurs
qui sont épuisés ça peut être produit au
rejet répété qui donne le sentiment que
personne ne s'intéresse à vous un
phénomène que ressentent environ 65% des
hommes et 40% des femmes mais aussi au
fait d'avoir trop de succès car ce qui a
le plus d'impact c'est la surabondance
des choix plus vous avez d'options plus
c'est difficile d'être sûr de soi est-ce
que vous parlez à la bonne personne
l'autre profil était peut-être mieux et
si vous aviez raté la chance de votre
vie ça donne lieu à une dissonance
cognitive impossible de savoir si vous
avez pris la bonne décision mais décide
de rencontre ont un autre problème si ça
permet aux gens de s'ouvrir plus
facilement l'anonymat a aussi des
dérives par exemple un tas de personnes
les utilisent alors qu'ils sont déjà en
relation sans vous prévenir bien sûr
rien que sur tinder on parle de 18 à 25%
suivant les études difficile de donner
sa confiance dans ces conditions
certains sites sont carrément
spécialisés dans l'adultère mais c'est
rien à côté des comportements
ouvertement toxiques et là
malheureusement les premières victimes
ce sont les femmes presque 60% des 18-34
ans disent avoir reçu des photos
explicites sans rien avoir demandé 44%
ce sont déjà fait insulter et 19% ont
été menacés de violence ou encore les
types qui vous retrouve sur Instagram
grâce à votre nom pour continuer de vous
écrire et ça sans parler des arnaques
des mensonges ou même des guet-apens des
types qui flirtent avec vous sur le site
vous donne rendez-vous puis une fois sur
place vous font les poches vous tabac ou
pire on est obligé de développer des
outils pour y faire face des IA
antidique comme celle de bumble qui
analyse les messages pour bloquer les
contenus problématiques ou carrément
créer des applis qui laissent les femmes
décider si elles veulent parler ou non
tout ça ça n'aide pas à combattre les
clichés surtout quand ils sont validés
par les statistiques oui les hommes
cherchent généralement des relations
plus courtes que les femmes écrivent
plus de messages reçoivent moins de
réponses et accordent plus d'importance
à l'aspect physique mais est-ce que
malgré ses défauts on a vraiment une
raison de s'y opposer ça fait bientôt 10
ans que le moyen le plus commun de
rencontrer un partenaire c'est sur
Internet et même quand vous flashez sur
des gens en soirée ou via des amis ça
vous empêche pas de juger le physique de
tomber sur des types bizarres et une
fois rentré chez vous de faire
connaissance par SMS maintenant qu'on a
fait le tour vous pouvez raconter vos
meilleurs et vos pires histoires en
commentaire promis on juge pas
[Musique]